partial orders are another way to talk
about digraphs and they offer to us an
interesting lesson in the idea of
axiomatic a mathematical structure and
mathematical ideas so let's begin by
discussing some of the properties that
we're going to use to axiom a ties
partial orders and digraphs so if we
think about walks in a digraph the basic
property of walks is that if you have a
walk from u to V and you have a walk
from V to W then you put the two walks
together and you wind up with a walk
from u to W expressed in terms of the
positive pet walk relation in G what
this is saying is that if u g + v + v g
+ w then u g + w and that abstract
property which i'm highlighting with the
magenta box when you apply it to an
arbitrary relation is called the
transitivity property so a relation R on
a set that is R is relating the domain
and codomain of are the same is that you
are V and V are W implies you are W and
a relation that has that property is
said to be transitive and of course what
we've just seen is that the positive
path relation of any graph G is
transitive another way to say
transitivity is to read you are V is
saying there's an edge from u to V and
what this says is that if there's an
edge from u to V and an edge from V to W
there's an edge from u to W or in other
words if there's a path of length 2
there's a path of length 1 and then by
easy induction it follows that if
there's a path of any length between of
any positive lengths between two
vertices then in fact there's a path of
length 1 that is an edge between them
okay so the basic theorem that we have
to begin with is what is transitivity
capturing as a property of a relation
and a relation r is transitive if and
only if in fact R is equal to the
positive walk relation for some digraph
J the proof of this is basically trivial
because you can let the relation R be
the digraph that it's the positive path
relation of if we look now at directed
acyclic graphs then what we have is that
if there's a positive length path from a
vertex u to a vertex V then since
there's no cycles in a directed acyclic
graph there can't be a path back from V
to u and that property is called a
symmetry so the plus which is the
positive path relation in a dag has this
asymmetry property namely if you can get
to V by a positive length path and it's
not possible for V to get back to you by
a positive length path so abstracted you
are V implies Naqvi are you that's the
asymmetry property of an arbitrary
relation r and by definition of a cyclic
d+ is a such is a symmetric in a graph
without cycles okay a strict partial
order is simply a relation that has
these two properties of being transitive
an asymmetric and some examples of
strict partial orders are the proper
containment relation on sets which we've
previously commented can be viewed as a
dag but now it satisfies transitivity
and the fact that if one sets properly
contained in another the second one
can't be properly contained in the first
because proper means you have something
extra the indirect prerequisite relation
on MIT subjects would be another example
of a strict
was it if I'm a prerequisite of you you
can't be a prerequisite of me and
finally the less than relation on real
numbers these are all examples of strict
partial orders and putting together the
previous reasoning what we can say is
that a relation R is a strict partial
order if and only if R is the positive
path relation for some great dag Dean
so the axioms that define strict partial
order namely transitivity and asymmetry
can be said abstractly capture the
property of a relation that it comes
from a dag another important property of
partial orders is the idea of being path
total or linear as some authors call it
and the simple definition of path total
is that given any two elements one is
going to be bigger than the other with
respect to the relation most familiar
example that would be the less than
relation or the less than or equal to
relation on the reals given any two
distinct real numbers x and y either X
is less than Y or Y is less than X and
we take that property for granted now
the frontal definition then is simply
that if X is not equal to Y then either
X are Y or Y are x and a relation R that
has that property is called path total
another way to say it is that there are
no incomparable elements under R and
I've again highlighted with a magenta
box this property which is called path
totality what another way to say that
path total is that the whole order looks
like a chain if you give me a bunch of
elements there's gonna have to be a
biggest one and then its next biggest
one and so on assume you give me any
finite set of elements so the basic
example again of path total would be
number properties of bigger than and a
basic example of something that would
typically not be path total would be
lets say subset containment where you
can perfectly well have two sets neither
of which
is contained in the other so a weak
partial order is a small variation of a
strict partial order that is another
familiar concept where we take the
strict property which guarantees that
nothing's related to itself and we relax
it so a strict partial order is just
like a weak partial order except that
the condition that there's no positive
length path between an element and
itself is relaxed so in fact it's not
only relaxed but it's completely denied
in a weak partial order we insist that
every element is related to itself an
example of that would be the less than
or equal to relation sorry the the
improper containment relation the
ordinary subset relation on sets where
now a is a subset with a bar under it a
is just a subset of a not necessarily a
strict subset or a proper subset means
that in fact a is a subset of a and then
less than or equal to when you put the
little bar under the less than sign to
indicate that equality is also a
possibility you get a weak partial order
on the real numbers so the property that
distinguishes the weak from the strict
is this property of reflexivity a
relation R on a set is reflexive if
every element is related to itself if
and only if a are a for all little a in
the domain capital A and what we can
observe immediately is that the path of
the walk relation G star which includes
walks of length zero is reflexive
because by definition there is a length
zero walk from any vertex to itself so
if you're going to play with axioms then
you can reformulate a symmetry the idea
of a symmetry except for elements being
related to themselves
it's called anti symmetry and it says
that a relation r is anti-symmetric if
an
if it's asymmetric except for the AR a
case and more precisely the difference
between asymmetry and anti symmetry is
that in asymmetry a ra is never allowed
and an anti symmetry a ra is a
possibility it's not disallowed so an
anti symmetric relation on our stated
abstractly is that you are V implies not
V are you for you not equal to V so the
first line is exactly the statement of
asymmetry and then I add this proviso
that it only has to hold when the U and
the V are not equal that's the formal
way of saying anti symmetry is the same
as a symmetry except for a ra and the
the walk relation in a digraph which
includes length zero walks is
anti-symmetric so with partial orders
just what you get when you put these
things together weak partial order is
transitive anti-symmetric and reflexive
so in a weak partial order we insist
that every element be related to itself
so there's a lissa is the quick remark a
symmetric means implies nothing's
related to itself
reflexive implies everything is related
to itself and it's possible that there
be some graph that in which some
elements are related to themselves and
some not that would be something that
was neither a strict nor a weak partial
order
it would just be transitive and
anti-symmetric those don't come up much
and so we don't bother to give them a
name or talk about them and finally the
theorem that summarizes up this whole
story is that R is a weak partial order
if and only if R is equal to the walk
relation for some dag including length
zero walks